What we're looking at here is actually a year's NIT based code blue computer kit original CP/M was written for the 8080
The said 80s is an extension of the 8080. So it runs all of the 8080 code
So this is actually running one of the original versions of CP/M exactly as it would have done back in the day, right? So
Initially, there's a small little little bootloader and we select to boot into CP/M
This is now money lead CP/M the specific BIOS for this is written by a guy called grants earned
He done need to face it for
this this generic hardware stuff, so
fantastic work there, but then the B dose and the
The CCP is all original CP/M stuff that's sliding in there
So we are back to what a lot of people YC is a familiar command prompt
We're at the I I disk command prompt
So we can pick up a directory
What are the fantastic things about CP/M was there was such a wealth of software
There was business software things like WordStar was the first real word processor. That was the killer app for it
There was debase the database program
so if you if you if he was a business, that's a great reason to use CP/M because you don't actually do your
Accounts on it and all stuff like that
There was also games all sorts of utilities and stuff like that
But it was also fairly easy to fight to write your own programs as long as you know a bit upset IT assembly code
CP/M includes the tools to actually write
your assembly
Program compile it turn it into an executable
and they just bud there as your and whatever you need that program to do well, so it's you would use to write your
assembly code these et is the assembler and that that will actually create your
program from your source code that you voted Edie Edie
EDD sorry, I'm gonna get so so many comments about that Auto so it's all kids
of course a classic adventure game regular views
We run Zork or a version of Zork on the pdp-11 a few weeks. Yes
I've followed her to 12. Y/o, I've got I've got furthered of what he did
But it all honesty you but I was played about with it first
First of all try to find my way around the the big white house and coming across monsters and stuff
I didn't get that much further, but it is exactly the same programming ones on CP/M. There's there's a whole wealth of
of
Tech space adventure games for CP/M which are yeah, which were all fantastic if you like that that kind of thing. There are CP/M
emulators online or
You could be could download and actually run CP/M on your machine. So although originally CP/M was written for the 8080
Subsequently, that means it. Well. It runs on these NIT. It was also later on ported over to the
The
it also runs on the
8086 I ad send pc infrastructure as well as one or two other things
I think there's said 8000 and the couple other things as well
So yeah, there were
Quite a few other Dodds nit machines eventually the read CP/M. CP/M doesn't know or care about graphics
It knows at least to send out something the way I've got this set up at the moment
This is just a serial terminal. So all this does is send out serial data
But yeah with a suitable graphics card of the suitable BIOS it will do pretty good graphics
as you'll see from this that's
Absolutely horrible
It's ended out all of the PT 100 control codes for the game there a lot being interpreted properly by
My avoid requires a graphics card
Okay, so you've got a different way of looking at it out of the RC 2014 comes the war s key data
Which I've put into a total web you later on a UNIX machine
So it's it's displayed exactly what it should be displayed as opposed to what the quality PI's displayed
So got ourselves a little game here if I play one player game
let's see how we do all this all the little C characters that's worried about
It so it was like a familiar layout to me
I'm sure they didn't steal this idea for any any arcade machines
Go grab a power pill would go to eat some monsters
All the fun of joys of Earth ASCII archives grape
Yahoo
So what we got here then this is one of the biggest selling machines that read CP/M. It's the the Illustrated PCW 1512
Yeah, very popular in the UK market. I don't know that he done so great outside of the UK
It was sold effectively as a word processor, but it said IP base they bundled it with
CP/M so obviously the guys are edge to edge vote the BIOS to talk to their their hardware side of things
The rest of it is standard CP/M as its booted up one of the things you can see there
It's running a few very basic CP/M commands. So it's setting the default directory. It's copied over pip
it's copied over set and it's copied over stuff via the shadows is effectively the same kind of thing because you
autoexec.bat and stuff like that that
people for me at least MSDOS rolled will will be familiar with
so
Once that's all booted up
you can then do
Similar things like get a directory listing see what's odd. Their syntax looks familiar. Actually, doesn't it?
I mean for those of us used to dos yes. Yeah, the syntax is very very familiar
It's it's it's almost a combination of DOS and a little bit of Linux in there as well
I'm sure there's be inspiration these be both both directions
They are because of the way that CPM work to the fact that it was so popular
That's why Microsoft ms-dos was a cloud to look just like it
It's a bunch of smaller learning curve to go up to ms-dos than what it is to something completely different
So, sometimes he floppies wood dies he often would make backup copies
Let's try this one
Sounds more hopeful and so there was this game called Lander which became the full game's arch